works all year to get to this spot right
here male we knew we had to earn this
for the next one but you guys know this
isn't the one we set out to get right we
didn't say how to give this one the hell
of accomplishment by everyone in here
house as cool of a game as I've been a
part of man enjoy tonight enjoy each
other
all right guys with the starting to
finishing our goals right away it starts
tomorrow yeah this whole first week is
the biggest jump you can get on that
team right you've been there before it's
hectic as can be when we get down there
I haven't made the whole schedule Cal
Shanahan coach to the 49ers in the
locker room after the 37 to 20 victory
over the Green Bay Packers that has put
Shanahan and the 49ers in the Super Bowl
the 49ers going for their first Super
Bowl victory in 25 years back in the
stadium where they won their last when
Chris and look I will admit I was wrong
I underestimated how big strong and fast
and physical the 49ers would be with a
running game that could not be stopped
the Vikings couldn't stop it in the
second half last week the Packers
couldn't stop it at all just so much so
that Rahim most had had the most rushing
yards of any 49ers player ever and Jimmy
Garoppolo threw eight passes in the
whole game yeah I mean it's remarkable
you know we started out the season in
you know in Chicago doing Green Bay
Chicago right we were really impressed
with what we saw in person by Green Bay
we went wow they're a good-looking team
I know we went last week and saw the
49ers play the Vikings and that went wow
this is an amazing looking team and you
just mentioned it I think that's really
what it is first off it's a credit to
Kyle Shanahan John Lynch what they built
there in San Francisco a lot of big
really aggressive people who just have
no hesitation in their game their
physicality they throw their bodies
around with just reckless abandon and
that shows and then you add that to a
schematic Algeria Han on the offensive
side of the ball and you get a steamroll
session for an NFC championship game and
I think that's what jumps out I mean
you're right Garoppolo did
have to do anything but everybody else
was hitting on all cylinders to where
they just whooped the crap out of the
Green Bay Packers yes and the 49ers will
be in the Super Bowl for the seventh
time going for win number six matching
the Patriots and the Steelers if they
pulled it off they have yet to trail in
the postseason after rolling over the
Vikings and the Packers and Kris I
talked about this last hour yeah think
of how different it could have been for
the 49ers if Jacob Hollister gains two
more inches yeah if Drake Greenlaw
doesn't break off from that zone that he
was covering to his left and push back
to the right to get to Hollister and
keep him out of the end zone 49ers would
have been the five seed with no time off
on the road having to do it the hard way
I don't think we'd be talking about them
today if Jacob Hollister gets that extra
two inches with the football and here we
are
49ers logging down the one seat taken
care of the Vikings taking care of the
Packers and it really was never in doubt
yesterday there was a moment the second
half where the Packers made a little
interesting but the thing is you can
start scoring points but you can't stop
the 49ers when you're running and this
is that look this is what makes a coach
a genius you not trying to outsmart
yourself or anyone else you're not
trying to show off
you just find something that works and
even if it's not flashy even if it's not
fun because the ball is not soaring
through the air it works and you win and
winning is fun and they've got that
formula where they it's amazing I was
rattling off Super Bowl seven stats last
hour Bob Griese 8 for 11 in Super Bowl
setup right and we'd look at that today
and say my god that's a joke 6 for 8
yeah who's Garoppolo yesterday well I
mean this has been a little bit of the
theme of the playoffs I mean you know
with Ryan Tannehill the Titans they won
two games with him you know basically
throwing the ball 10 times a game so
when you dominate the line of scrimmage
that way on the offensive side of the
ball you have weapons that are very
versatile like a d bo samuel who can run
the ball and then the creativity the
creativity of Shanahan's run game it's
just off the charts I mean that's what
we saw yesterday we saw the pinnacle of
a team that not only has great talent
and great talent
Gaston making the run game good but then
a coach who's just an outside-the-box
thinker and it's just one great play
after another I mean I've never seen
anything like it it's it's an eight yard
run it's a ten yard run it's a five yard
run it's a 12 yard run I mean they just
rip them off back and forth and then you
get over the defensive side of the ball
and it goes back to a formula we talk
about all the time Mike when you want to
play great quarterbacks or any great
team they can get there with four people
and that would so makes them tough
that's why they're the best team in
football and that's why they are where
they are I mean hey they've had a lot of
moments of dominating teams this year I
know down the stretch it wasn't good but
they've shown that they are capable of
doing what we saw on Sunday and with the
emotions in the moment they rise to the
occasion and how about rahim most 'red
yeah cut by six other teams and you know
when they used to show the guy getting
cut on hard knocks and I'm glad they
don't anymore that's a very private
personal moment that shouldn't be
displayed to the world but you see these
guys who get assured out and you'll
wonder Chris at what point do they just
give it up like how many times do you
have to be cut before you say okay
that's it I get it
this isn't for me and the answer is it's
more than six I don't know what the
number is but it's more than six because
rahim most 'red has shown you can still
have success in the NFL if you have
persistence if you have perseverance and
if you develop a willingness to embrace
the adversity embrace the rejection and
use it as fuel and and I want to read
something he said yesterday because I
think this is great for anybody who's
going through any type of adversity in
their lives and he's trying to get to
somewhere that they just can't get and
they keep having the door slammed in
their face look at Rahim most hurt and
find that will to keep knocking on the
door and don't give up in your pursuit
he said back in 2015 when he was with
the Browns his wife is from Cleveland we
thought we had something in the bag he
made the roster and then the next day
after making it to the 53-man roster he
got cut and having me go through that it
made me stronger
I got immune to being cut
said and I wanted to show the world what
I can do and honestly it was just one of
those things where I really had to talk
with my wife and I was saying what do
you think should happen after that cut
and she said if you love your job if you
love this sport you will do anything for
it and if you love what you do you do
anything for it and that was my
philosophy from here on out that applies
to anything folks anything that you want
to do if you love it
you keep throwing yourself into it you
don't take no for an answer
you don't take rejection and you keep
going in her he moster 220 yards
yesterday I asked him after the game
when did you last for us for 220 yards
he said thirty minutes ago they said
before that he said never never he had
never had a day like yesterday what a
day to have it Chris like an amazing day
you know and again yeah I remember you
know watching them in preseason games in
Cleveland and Indianapolis and seeing a
talent right but here was a guy that
yeah I got caught up with some of the
politics of full you know football team
and yes lost you know to other low men
on the on the roster totem pole whatever
it may be but he gets to a place that
his skillset really fits the style of
the head coach and then then again this
goes back to Shanahan and what we see on
the field you know one thing I know that
when I've ever talked to Kyle about
scouting players and things like that he
wants players with no hesitation in
their game none he wants a middle
linebacker that when they see the
running back over to the hole they don't
like pause for one second they go in and
they try to knock his head off he wants
a running back that when you see a hole
you put your foot in the ground and you
run through that hole as fast as you can
and who cares about the contact and
that's what rahim most heard is he's one
of those guys that to what you are
saying will run through a wall for a
coach and we're seeing that with the
aggression on which he's playing and of
course that first touchdown that you're
seeing here on TV that jump-started the
game and you're right from that point on
Mike I don't know how you felt but I
felt oh man Green Bay is in trouble and
I don't like the look of this and I
don't think they're gonna be able to
beat San Francisco the first touchdown
of the
I said here we go yes because it just
felt like the floodgates were gonna open
and open they did the Packers you did
have an answer and you know when you
watch these plays and at full speed it's
hard to get the appreciation but you
look at the lineman for both teams and
that push coming off of the ball and it
just feels like the Packers players are
just kind of flailing around and some of
the guys are just kind of going
half-speed after they break away from
that initial block those 49ers players
are relentless and they're the ones who
get it done and you throw in George
killing Kyle you stick the tight end and
the back respectively right you've got
an army of guys who can block who can
open the hole to make it easier whether
it's Raheem most dirt Evan Coleman who
got injured yesterday Matt Breda whoever
they put back there is gonna be able to
gain yardage when you have an offensive
line a tight end and a fullback who are
fully committed to busting you in the
mouth old-school football in this age of
passing and statistics and fantasy
football and it's it's fun to watch the
ball sail through the air and what
Patrick Holmes and the Chiefs do is
great but the old-school stuff yeah you
get the right guys and it still works
it still works it's it's still fun to
watch I mean that's that's what's fun
you know and you know I think the other
thing too with the creativity the big
plays I just I'm always amazed in
playoff football that you know at some
point or another you play a team where
they expose you and your real issues as
a football team rise to the top every
now and then you see a team that kind of
gets away with it but this was one of
these games where I just looked at it
went hey one of the one of the issues we
talked about with Green Bay all year was
run defense it had gotten better down
the stretch but here in the biggest
moment of the year against a team that
can really run the football it reared
its ugly head once again inconsistencies
on the offenses out of the ball I mean
how many games did we see the Packers
come out put up points and then kind of
just barely hold on to win because they
couldn't consistently drive the ball or
keep drives together and all those
things came to a pinnacle yesterday
against a team that was better than they
have work to do they have work to do and
the San Francisco 49ers are one of those
teams that's almost perfect in a lot of
ways and set up to be really good and a
pain in the butt for the NFC for a long
time here but that's the brilliance
what your tattoo buddy kyle has done
right when you have the other team on
the ropes running the ball running the
ball running ball why do you feel
compelled to go play-action throw to the
end zone from the 45 yard line or do a
little flea flicker like we often see
when a team starts to get a head of
steam running the ball they decide to do
something cute you don't need to they
can't stop you and the more you're able
to do it the more it demoralizes that
defense to the point where it's
pointless yeah it didn't matter how many
times the Packers are gonna drive down
the field and score in the third and
fourth quarter yesterday when they
finally woke up offensively because they
were never going to be able to slow down
that offense because it was good
old-fashioned our guys are bigger
stronger and more determined than your
guys it's just that simple and they made
it work well it goes back to the old
same like we talked about this a lot
with great football teams right you've
got to be great at something what is
your identity and they have an identity
in San Francisco and then off of that
yeah
teams have to put all their stock into
stopping this one thing and what
happened to Green Bay yesterday is they
tried to pack the middle of the defense
they tried to get in there we're not
gonna let them run inside on us and do
that and Shanahan smart and he said fine
I got 25 different toss plays to get out
on the edge I'll cram all you guys down
in there to stop the inside run you'll
all get stuck running into each other
I'll get Mozart out on the edge and you
know good night and that's just good
coaching and good game game planning by
Shanahan Matt Lafleur Packers coach said
after the game that is a fast team and
they were better faster and more
physical than us tonight they got us
they got after us two games this year
right now they're the gold standard in
the NFC and they definitely are in there
heading back to the Super Bowl for the
Packers though we're gonna flip it
around what went wrong with them
offensively and where do they stand in
this hierarchy of the NFC moving forward
their quarterback is pretty optimistic
about the future
should he be we'll discuss that one pft
live continues
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports